yeah yeah i mean uh going back to the
fear thing do you know what fear
like fascinates me uh i forgot what the
name is like tyrophobia or something
that's the the one with like the phobia
yeah triple phobia
the one where you like where you see
like a lot of small horns because like
i didn't have a fear of this and i think
that literally was a fear that got
garnered because of the internet yeah
because i um because we had like the
lily pond plants in thailand
and i grew up with them so you know the
little little seeds
so i i was used to seeing this site
everywhere so i had no fear of it and
then
watching enough [ __ ] youtube videos
about it about
about this fear i i slowly gained it
over time because i just saw these
different like [ __ ]
disgusting disgusting photos it wasn't
for me it wasn't even like a youtube
video it was literally just typing
triple phobia onto google images
and just the first thing you see is just
this rogue
don't [ __ ] show anything don't show
it in the video but
you guys if you want to then go for it
i'm warning you though it's [ __ ]
gross i'm kind of glad that i had that
though because that made me like
understand because you know as when i
was growing up i don't really have again
even though i was claustrophobic i'm not
ready anymore i don't really
give a [ __ ] now um uh like
i feel that that helped me understand
when people have fears that don't make
sense
yeah because before that i didn't really
get it like if someone was scared of
like
falling i'm like oh it's just a form and
you'll be fine but a little bit of hype
it's safe
but now i get it because from that i'm
like this makes no sense why a bunch of
little circles
make me feel gross but now i get it my
my fear of heights is really weird
because
i'm it's only like certain levels of
heights that get me
queasy because you know like if you go
up to like the tokyo tower yeah yeah
yeah there's like
there's parts of it where the floor is
made out of class
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
i'm totally okay with that okay yeah but
you take me onto the balcony of like a
ten-story building and make me look down
that [ __ ] me up yeah i think it's
because it might be because like say
with like you know tokyo tower like the
glass thing right
yeah you know that is safe right like
you could stand on that
you can jump on that like man you trust
the engineering yeah i do it's like it's
like they wouldn't
this is japanese standards of
engineering they wouldn't put this here
if there was a fear that somebody could
jump on this and you could break through
it right like yeah so i know i can stand
on that look down and [ __ ] around with
it because i know that's safe [ __ ]
around
what are you doing getting your chisel
out no i could like i'd [ __ ] stomp on
and jump around and stuff just to like
freak out whoever i'm with
and i'm fine with that that doesn't tell
me all because i know
that's safe but you put me onto like a
balcony right
and i know nobody won't do it but the
fear of somebody could come behind me
right now and just push me over the edge
that's what that scares me that's true i
i have that fear
um whenever i stand on the platform edge
in
japanese uh japanese trains
oh really yeah yeah because i've seen
enough anime
where the main character gets shoved off
and
and there's nothing they can do and i i
feel that so whenever i'm like standing
on the edge of a platform
i literally have to stand at a 90 degree
angle because otherwise
otherwise i just i just feel
uncomfortable i feel like someone could
go shut up
yeah yeah exactly because at least at
least if someone tries to push me on the
side i can like
try to stop the momentum but there's
literally nothing i can do
i don't walk because like normally the
platform is so
full right so and people don't stand on
the yellow part which is like the danger
zone yeah but like if i need to get to
the other side i'll walk on the danger
zone but
i won't walk there if the train's coming
yeah yeah i'm not risking being nudged
or something
but you know if there's no train if i if
i get pushed on the tracks i'll just get
back up
someone will someone will grab me right
i don't know man i've seen someone get
like falling onto the tracks before
really yeah what happened did people
help him
i mean obviously like they have those
like emergency buttons that alert
everybody so like i think it was
it was obviously like some drunk dude
just out of his mind yeah i think
there's posters all around the
japanese stations being like oh don't be
drunk i think it's something like
60 to 70 percent of people who fall into
the drax
are usually because they're drunk yeah
yeah which makes sense but yeah i saw
some dude
like kind of stumble around and i was
like oh god this guy's getting pretty
close to the edge and then
sure enough he just went oh wait there
was someone on our station one time i
remember seeing that
yeah there's a bunch of stretches and
stuff unfortunately they fell and hit
their head pretty bad
yeah well that's the thing right the gap
is big it's
really deep yeah so if you're not
careful you can hurt yourself even
if there's no training coming but yeah